hace pocos minutos aquí a mis espaldas
ocurrió la primera protesta que ha
habido dentro del Blue song donde son
las negociaciones de la Copa 27 y esto
es toda una novedad porque Egipto ha
sido muy restrictivo con las
manifestaciones dentro de la Cumbre
climática por ejemplo
que la detención de los activistas
aumentó de carala con 27 por llamar a
protestas aquí en este evento y de hecho
el indio allí rayagopal fue detenido el
31 de octubre por Iniciar una caminata
de 8 días desde el Cairo a charmershake
la ciudad donde se realiza la cop 27 sin
embargo fue liberado al día siguiente
ante las críticas internacionales
también se ha conocido ampliamente el
caso del egipcio británico a la app el
fatá quien desde el domingo inició una
huelga y dejó de consumir agua estando
en la prisión donde cumple 5 años de
cárcel además Egipto ha impuesto
múltiples puestos de control en El Cairo
e instaló cerca de 800 cámaras en los
taxis de charmet
y además se ha destacado por tener unas
restricciones que nunca se habían visto
en anteriores como instaurar un permiso
que tienen que solicitar con 36 horas de
antelación las organizaciones que
quieran manifestarse
porque día a día seguimos teniendo
promesas de los líderes mundiales sobre
financiación climática pero cuando
regresamos no obtenemos nada y luego
hablan de la otra cop de hecho Ya
empezaron a hablar de la cop28 aquí en
la cop27 entonces lo que les decimos es
que no se trata de hablar se trata de
financiación climática vennos el dinero
no queremos charlas y con esta
información Nos despedimos por ahora
desde pero sigan ustedes con más en
francés 24